so i've drawn multiple versions of the
exact same surface s five
copies of that exact same surface and
what i want to do is think about the
value of the line integral let me write
this down the value of the line integral
of f
f
dot d r
d r where f is the vector field that
i've drawn in magenta in each of these
diagrams and obviously it's different in
each of these diagrams and the only part
of the vector field that i've drawn is
the part that's along the surface i
could have drawn the part of the vector
field that's off the surface but we're
only going to be concerned with what's
going on on the surface so the vector
field could be defined in this entire
three-dimensional space in here as well
and these are obviously different vector
fields and we can see that visually
based on how we drew it and the contour
that we care about remember we're going
to take a line integral so the path
matters the path that we care about is
the
counterclockwise boundary of our surface
so it's going to be this right over here
the counterclockwise
boundary of our surface is what we're
going to be taking
f
dot dr along so this right over here and
let me draw the orientation it's going
to be counterclockwise we're going to do
it in every one of these
every one of these situations every for
every one of these surfaces and every
one of these f's and what i really want
to think about is how the value of f dot
dr over that contour how it might change
from example to example and obviously
the only difference between each of
these is what the vector field f is
doing
so first let's think about this example
right over here at this part of the
contour this bottom part right over here
our vector field is going in the exact
same direction as our line as our
contour so it's going to be we're going
to get positive values of f dot dr down
here and we're going to keep summing
them up we're taking an integral then as
we go up the curve right of oris we go
kind of uphill right over here we see
that our vector field is going
essentially orthogonal it's going
perpendicular it's going perpendicular
to our contour so our f dot dr we're not
going to get any value from that f dot d
r and all of these right at this part of
the contour it's all going to be zero so
we're not going to get anything right
over there actually let me just write
nothing so we get nothing
right over there maybe i'll write zero
all right we'll get zero right over
there and then up here when we're at
this part of the contour
our vector field is going in the exact
opposite direction as our path up here
our path is going i guess from the right
to the left while our vector field is
going from the left to the right and so
we're actually going to get negative
values we are going to get negative
values up here and they're going to sum
up to a reasonable negative value and if
the vector field is constant and i kind
of drew it like it is and if this length
is equal to this length then these two
values are going to cancel out when you
add the this positive sum to this
negative sum they're going to be zero
and then once again when you go downhill
again the vector field is perpendicular
to our actual path so we're going to get
zero so the base based on the way i've
i've described it your line integral of
f dot d r for this version of f in this
example right over here it might all
cancel out you will get something if we
make the assumptions that i made
this might be equal to zero so in this
example
f
f dot dr f dot dr could be equal to zero
now let's think about what's going on in
this situation in this one just like the
last one as we go along the bottom the
vector field is going in the exact same
direction as our contour so we're going
to get positive values and once we go up
the hill the vector field is going
perpendicular to our path so it's not
going to add anything really to it so
we're just going to get 0 along this
part but then up here our vector field
has switched directions and it's once
again it's going in the exact same
direction as our path so we're going to
get more positive values right over
there and then as we go down here it's
not going to add anything because our
vector field is perpendicular to our
path so we're going to get 0. but notice
this now these two ends don't cancel out
with each other we're going to get a
positive value
we are going to get a positive value and
what was the difference between this
version of f this vector field and this
vector field right over here well this
vector field switched directions so that
the top part didn't cancel out with the
bottom part or another way to think
about it is
it had some curl there's a little bit of
spinning going on if this was describing
the velocity of a fluid and if you were
to put a stick if you were to put a
stick right over there on the surface
the stick would spin it has some spin or
some curl however you want to describe
it this right over here has no curl if
you put a stick right over here it would
just flow with the fluid but the stick
itself would not spin so we got a
positive value for the line integral in
this situation and we also have it looks
like a positive curl
positive
positive curl
now let's think about this one in this
situation as we go along this part of
our contour our our vector field f is
going the exact same direction so we're
going to get positive values now as we
go
uphill
our vector field f it's also kind of
turned in that direction and so we'll
get more positive values and now as we
go in that direction our vector field f
is still going in the direction of our
contour we're going to get more positive
values and as we go down once again the
vector field f is going in the direction
of our contour so we'll get even more
positive values so this in this
situation
the value of our line integral of f dot
dr is even more positive
more
more positive and we see that this that
the actual vector field along the
surface and remember the vector field
might be doing all sorts of crazy things
off the surface actually let me draw
that in that same magenta color
it might be doing all sorts of crazy
things off the surface but what we
really care about is what's happening on
the surface and because this vector
field is i guess you could say curling
or spinning along the surface it allows
it to go with the boundary along all the
points and we get a very positive value
for this line integral so we have a
higher curl so more curl
more curl
it looks like is leading to a more
positive line integral
now let's think about what's happening
in this situation right over here
this situation down here our vector
field is going in the same direction as
our path so we're going to get positive
values
just like the first situation as we go
up the hill like this or up the surface
like that our vector field is
perpendicular our surface so it's really
not going to add anything to our line
integral and then as we go as we go
along this top part this first part of
the top part right over here the vector
field is going against us so it's
negative right over here we're going in
the exact opposite direction of our path
and then right as we get to the end the
vector field flips direction and we get
a little bit of positive right over here
because it's a little bit of it going in
the same direction and then we go back
downhill when we go back downhill it
adds nothing because our vector field is
going perpendicular going perpendicular
to our path so the big difference
between this case and the case up here
is the case up here or actually the big
difference this well actually i could
compare between these two or these two
but the difference between this one and
this one is that at least this part of
the vector field has switched directions
so we get a little bit of positive value
and one way to think about it this one
is going to be less positive than that
if we take the line integral but more
positive than that and one other way to
think about it is we have a little bit
of curl going on right over here our
vector field switch directions right
around there or or i guess you could say
that it's spinning right around there so
if you put a stick if that was in the
water it would start spinning but
everywhere else there isn't a lot of
curl so you have some curl but it's over
a little small region of the surface
while over here you had curl going on
over a larger surface of the a larger
portion of our surface
and so up here you had a more positive
curl more positive line integral here
you have a curl over less of the surface
and you're going to have a less positive
line integral now let's think about this
one over here
this vector field along the surface
there is some curl there's some curl
going on right over there
if you put a stick in the water if you
view that as the velocity of water the
stick would spin so you have some curl
and you also actually have but then it
switches direction again so you have
curl there as well and it's actually
curl in the opposite direction so they
to some degree if you were to sum all of
this up maybe it would cancel out and it
makes sense it makes sense that it would
cancel out
because when you take the line integral
around the whole thing just like this
first situation you might it looks like
it'll add up to zero because even though
you have some curl the curls cancel out
each other and so when you go to this
top part of the surface you go the
vector field is going in the exact same
direction as this bottom part of the
surface so if you were to take your line
integral
if you were to take your line integral
the same one that we care about
just like the first situation it would
be positive down here zero as we go up
the curve and then as we go down here
the vector field has switched directions
twice so still going against the path of
our contours just like this first
situation so it'd be negative up there
and then as we go down it would be zero
so this thing right over here this thing
right over here also looks just like the
first one because the curls essentially
cancel out we switch direction twice so
over here our line integral our line
integral might also
might also be zero now the whole reason
why i went through this exercise is to
give you an intuition of why it might
make sense that if we have more curl
happening over more of this surface why
that might make the value of this line
integral be larger
and so hopefully it starts to give you
an intuition that maybe just maybe the
value of this line integral the value of
f
of f dot dr
dot dr over that contour over this this
contour that's going in the
counterclockwise direction we'll talk
more about orientation in future videos
maybe this is equal to the sum of the
curls over the surface and so let's
think about this it could be a surface
integral
so we're going to go over the surface
over the surface and what we care about
is the curl of f
we care about the curl
the curl of f but we don't just care
about the curl of f generally because f
might be spinning in a direction in a
way that's off the surface we care about
how much it's curling on the surface so
what we'd want to do is we would want to
take it we'd want to take the curl of f
and dot it with the normal vector at any
point of the surface and then multiply
that times
times the surface itself so then
multiply that times the surface itself
or another way of writing this and this
is just to say that the more surface
where we have more curling going on the
more that the line integral the value of
the line integral might be and we saw
that when we compared these three
examples and another way of writing all
of this is the surface integral let me
write the surface in that same brown
color the surface integral of the curl
of f
the curl of f which would just be
another vector that tells us how much
we're spinning
generally but we want to care how much
we're spinning along the surface so
we're taking the we're dotting with the
normal vector or another way to write
this whole thing is to say dot
dot
d s so if you take essentially the sum
along
across the entire surface of how much
we're curling how much we're spinning
along that surface that maybe just maybe
this will be equal to the value of the
line integral as we go around the
boundary of the surface and it actually
turns out that this is the case and i
obviously haven't proven it to you here
but hopefully you have some intuition
why this makes sense and this idea that
this is equal to this is called
is called stokes
stokes
theorem and we'll explore it more in the
next few videos